do the main grievances of the
demonstration is effectively another
five years of austerity and they're
selling off the public services and
about to be the destruction of what the
walking paths have spent generations
fighting for and winning and I can be
very worried about whether they'll be
any form of like welfare state of like
public services I'm even like you know
society and community left an energy
five year
I
as soon as they going they've just been
like well now we've got a fucker core
and we're going to basically cause more
disabled people today we're going to
take just the living allowances for
young people looking for jobs which it's
not based on sound economics it's just
class
nope capela you see the future